This lecture is about the
discriminative classifiers for text
categorization.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue talking about how to do text
categorization and cover discriminative
approaches.
This is a slide that you have seen from
the discussion of Naive Bayes
classifier, where we have shown that
although naive Bayes classifier tries
to model the generation of text data
from each categories, we can actually
use bayes rule and to eventually rewrite
the scoring function as you see on this
slide and this scoring function is
basically a
weighted combination of a lot of
word features where the feature values
are word count and the feature weights
are the log of probability ratios of
the word given by two distributions
here.
Now this kind of scoring function can
be actually a general scoring function
where we can in general represent text
data as a feature vector.
Of course the features don't have to
be all the words and their features can
be other signals that we want to use.
And we mentioned that this is
precisely
similar to logistic regression.
So in this lecture we're going to
introduce some discriminative
classifiers.
They try to model the conditional
distribution of labels given the data
directly rather than using Bayes rule
to compute that indirectly.
As we have seen in naive bayes.
So the general idea of logistical
regression is to model the dependency
of the binary response variable Y here,
On some predictors.
That are denoted as X.
So here we have also changed the
notation to X
For feature values you may recall in the
previous slide we have used Fi to
represent the feature values.
An here we use the notation of X
vector, which is more common when we
Introduce such machine learning
algorithms, so X is our input, it's a
vector.
And with M features.
And each feature has a value X sub I here
and our goal is model the dependency
of this binary response variable on all
these features.
So in our categorization problem we
have two categories, lets say theta 1 and
theta 2, and we can use the Y value to
denote the two categories.
And when Y is 1 it means the category of
the documents first class theta 1
Now the goal here is to model the
conditional probability of Y given X
directly as opposed to model the
generation of X&Y as in the case of
Naive Bayes.
And another advantage of this kind of
approach is that it would allow many
other features than words to be used
in this vector.
Since we're not modeling the generation
of this vector and we can plug in any
signals that we want, so this is
potentially advantages for doing text
categorization.
So most specifically, in logistic
regression the assumed functional
form of y depending on X is the
following, and this is very closed,
closely related to the log or log odds
that I introduced in the naive bayes or
log of probability ratio of the two
categories that you have seen on the
previous slide.
So that this is what I meant, right?
So in the case of Naive Bayes, we
compute this by using bayes rule and
eventually we have reached a formula
that look like this.
That looks like this.
But here we actually would assume
explicitly that we would model our
Probability of Y given X.
As directly as a function of these
features.
So most specifically, we assume that
log of the ratio of probability of y =
1 and the probability of y = 0.
Is a function of X.
And so it's a function of X, and it's a
linear combination of these feature
values, controlled by beta values.
And since we know that probability of
y = 0 is 1 minus probability of y = 1,
and this can be also written in this
way.
So this is a log odds ratio.
Here.
And so in logistic regression, we
basically assume that the probability
of y = 1  given X is dependent on this
linear combination of all these
features.
So it's just one of the many possible
ways of assuming that the dependency,
But this particular form has been quite
useful, and it has also has some nice
properties.
So if we rewrite this question to
actually express the probability of Y
given X in terms of X by taking by
getting rid of the logarithm and we get
this functional form and this is called
a logistical function, it's a
transformation of X into Y.
As you see.
on the right side here.
So that the Xs will be mapped into
a range of values from zero to 1.0.
You can see, and that's precisely what
we want.
Since we have a probability here.
And the function form looks like this.
So this is the basic idea of logistic
regression, and it's a very useful
classifier that can be used to do a lot
of classification tasks, including text
categorization.
So as in all cases of model, we would
be interested in estimating the
parameters and in fact in all the machine
learning programs.
Once you set up the model set of
objective function.
To model the classifier, then the next
step is to compute the parameter
values.
In general, we're going to adjust these
parameter values, optimize the
performance of classifier on the
training data.
So in our case, let's assume we have
The training data here, X i and Y i and
each pair is basically feature vector
of X and a known label for that X Y,
either one or zero.
So in our case we are interested in
maximizing this conditional likelihood.
The condition likelihood here is
basically to model y given the
observed X.
So it's not like a.
It's not like a modeling X, but rather
we're going to model this.
Note that this is a conditional
probability of Y given X.
And this is also precisely what we want
for classification.
Now, so the likelihood function would
be just a product over all the training
cases.
And in each case, this is the modeled
probability of observing this
particular training case.
So given a particular XI, how likely
we are going to observe the corresponding Y i
of course, Y I could be one or zero
and in fact the function form here
would vary depending on whether Y sub I
is one or zero.
If it's one will be taking this form.
And that's basically the logistical
regression function.
But what about this if it's 0?
Well, if it's zero then we have to use a
different form and that's this one.
Now how do we get this one?
That's just one minus the probability
of y = 1, right?
And you can easily see this now.
The key point here is that the function
form here depends on the observed.
Y I if it's one, it has a different
form than when it's 0.
And if you think about when we want to
maximize this probability we will
basically going to want this
probability to be as high as possible
when the label is one.
That means the document is in topic
one.
But if the document is not we are going to
maximize this value, and what's going
to happen is actually to make this
value as small as possible.
Because they sum to one.
When I maximize this one.
It's equivalent to minimize this one.
So you can see basically the if we
maximize the conditional likelihood
we're going to basically
try to make the prediction on the
training data as accurate as possible.
So, as in other cases, when compute
the maximum likelihood estimator
Basically lets go find a beta
value, a set of beta values that will
maximize this conditional likelihood.
And this again then gives us a standard
optimization problem.
In this case, it can be also solved in
many ways.
Newtons method is a popular way to
solve this problem.
There are other methods as well, but in
the end will we're going to get the set
of beta values once we have the beta
values, then we have a well defined
scoring function to help us classify a
document right?
So what's the function?
Well, it's this one.
If we have all the betavalues
already known, all we need is to
compute
The Xi's for that document.
And then plugging those values that
will give us a estimate.
The probability that the document is in
category one.
OK, so much for logistical regression.
Let's also introduce another
discriminative classifier called K
nearest neighbors.
Now in general, I should say there are
many such approaches.
And thorough introduction to all of them
is clearly beyond the scope of this
course and you should take a machine
learning course or read more about
machine learning to know about them.
Here, just want to include the basic
introduction to some of the most
commonly used classifiers, since you
might use them often for text
categorization.
So the second classifier, is called k
nearest neighbors.
In this approach, we're going to also
estimate the conditional probability of
label.
Given data, but in a very different
way.
So the idea is to keep all the training
examples and then once we see a text
object that we want to classify, we're
going to find the K examples in the
training set and that are most similar
to this text object.
Basically this is to find the neighbors
of this text object in the training
data set.
So once we found we found the
neighborhood and found the objects that
are close to the.
The object we're interested in
classifying and say we have found the K
nearest neighbors.
That's why this method is called K
And then we're going to assign the
category that's most common in these
neighbors.
Basically, we're going to allow these
neighbors to vote for the category of
the object that we're interested in
classifying.
Now that means if most of them have a
particular category, lets say category 1
then we're going to say this current
object will have category one.
This approach, can also be improved
by considering the distance of
a neighbor and the current object.
Basically, we can assume a close
neighbor will have more saying about
the category of this object, so we can
have we can give such a neighbor more
influence on the vote and we can take
weighted sum of their votes based on
the distances.
But the general idea is to look at the
neighborhood and then try to assess the
category based on the categories of the
neighbors.
Intuitively, this makes a lot of sense.
But mathematically, this can also be
regarded as a way to directly estimate
the conditional probability of label
given data that is P of Y given X.
Now I'm going to explain this intuition
in the moment, but before we proceed,
let me emphasize that we do need a
similarity function here in order for
this work.
I note that in naive base classifier we
did not need a similarity function.
An in logistical regression, we did not
talk about the similarity function
either.
But here we explicitly requires a
similarity function.
Now this similarity function.
Actually is a good opportunity for us
to inject any of our insights about
features.
Basically, effective features are those
that would make the objects that are in
the same category look more similar,
but distinguishing objects in different
categories.
So the design of this similarity
function is closely tied to the design
of the features in logistic regression.
and other classifiers, so let's
illustrate how K-NN works.
Suppose we have a lot of training
instances here.
And I've colored them differently and
to show just different categories.
Now suppose we have a new object in the
center that we want to classify.
So according to this approach we're going to
find the neighbors.
And let's first think of a special case
of finding just one neighbor, the closest
neighbor.
Now in this case, if the, let's assume
the closest neighbor is the box filled
with diamonds and so then we're going to
say.
Well, since this is in, this object is
in category of diamonds.
Let's say then we're going to say,
well, we're going to assign the same
Category to our text object.
But let's also look at the another
possibility of finding a larger
neighborhood.
So let's think about the four
neighbors.
In this case, we're going to include a
lot of other solid field boxes in red
or pink.
So in this case now we  are going to notice that
among the four neighbors there are actually
three neighbors in a different
category.
So if we take a vote, then we'll
conclude the object is actually of a
different category.
So this both illustrates how K
nearest neighbor works and also
illustrates some potential problems of
this classifier.
Basically the results might depend on
the K and indeed K is an important
parameter to optimize.
Now you can intuitively imagine if we
have a lot of neighbors around this
object and then we'll be OK because we
have a lot of neighbors for help us
decide categories.
But if we have only a few, then the
decision may not be reliable.
So on the one hand we want to find more
neighbors right?
And then we have more votes, but on the
other hand as we try to find the more
neighbors, we actually could risk on
getting neighbors that are not
really similar to this instance, they
might be actually far away as you try
to get more neighbors, so although you
get more neighbors to vote, but those
neighbors aren't necessary so helpful
because they are not very similar to
the object.
So the parameter as there has to be set
empirically and typically you can
optimize such a parameter by using
cross validation.
Basically, you're going to separate
your training data into two parts and
then you're going to use one part to
actually help you choose.
The
The parameter K here or some other
parameters in other classifiers, and
then you're going to assume this number
that works well on your training set
would be actually the best for your
future data.
So as I mentioned that KNN can be
actually regarded as estimate of
conditional probability of Y given X,
and that's why we put this in the
category of discriminative approaches.
So the key assumption that we made
in this approach is that the
distribution of the label given the
document or probability of a category
given document.
For example, probability of theta I
given document D is locally smoothed and
that just means we're going to assume
that this probability is the same for
all the documents in this region.
R  here.
And suppose we draw a neighborhood and
we're going to assume in this
neighborhood, since the data instances
are very similar, we're going
to assume that the conditional
distribution of the label, given the
data, would be roughly the same.
If D is not different, very different
than we're going to assume that the
probability of theta given D would be
also similar, and so that's a very key
assumption, and that that's.
That's actually important assumption
that would allow us to do a lot of
machine learning, but in reality,
whether this is true of course would
depend on how we define similarity,
because the neighborhood is largely
determined by our similarity function.
If our similarity function captures
objects that do follow similar
distributions, then this assumption is
OK.
But if our similarity function could
not capture that.
Obviously the assumption would be a
problem, and then the classifier would
not be accurate.
Let's proceed with this assumption.
Then what we are saying is that in
order to estimate the probability of a
category given a document, we can try
to estimate the probability of the
category given that entire region.
Now this has the benefit of course, of
bringing additional data points to help
us estimate this probability.
And so this is precise idea of KNN.
Basically now we can use the known
categories of all the documents in this
region to estimate this probability.
And I have even given a formula here
where you can see we just count the
topics in this region and then
normalize that by the total number of
documents in the region.
So the numerator that you see here c
of Theta and R is a count of the
documents in region R with category
Theta I.
Since these are training documents, we
know they're categories.
We can simply count how many times we
have seen sports here, how many times
we have seen science etc.
And then
denominator is just a total number of
documents
training documents in this region, so
this gives us a rough estimate of which
category is most popular in this
neighborhood, and we're going to assign
the popular category to our data
objective since it falls into this
region.